martial arts blood gore violence and
Russell Crowe with a big knife gun gotta
admit you're a bit intrigued the man
with the iron fists so the man with the
iron fist is written by Eli Roth and RZA
I believe I'm pronouncing it right RZA
I think it's RZA somehow I'm gonna screw
that up but really actually it's Raisa
or RCA just the letters and the movie is
exactly what you would expect from a
martial arts movie that's written by Eli
Roth and someone from the wu-tang clan
it's also directed by RZA so it's it's
their brainchild so in the man with the
iron fist is pretty standard kung fu
movie this one dude betrays this
other guy and kills them now that dude's
son is out for revenge against them then
you have Russell Crowe who's all argue
my business this is pleasure and Lucy
Liu who runs a whorehouse and then just
everyone kicks everyone's ass then you
had this one dude whose skin turns
completely into gold like Colossus from
x-men but instead of you know silver
it's gold and his skin just does that as
an automatic response like we try to
sneak up behind him and stab him in the
head his head's gonna turn to gold it's
all indestructible which begs the
question dudes riddled with tattoos like
how could he get tattoos however you
soon realizes the kind of moves you
cannot question those kinds of logistics
it wasn't created for people to be like
mm yes logic and reason this movie
simply exists to appeal to the rated-r
version of Big Trouble in Little China
fan in all of us and in that is the
movie cool yeah I had fun with it it was
pretty cool it's not a great movie I
recognize that I mean early on in the
movie you're like alright so Ryu from
the Street Fighter movie like the van
Damme Street Fighter movie is the bad
guy in this movie something tells me
this movie's not gonna win any awards
but it knows that you watch the trailer
and you know exactly what kind of movie
you're getting into let's just have
people kill the out of each other
with a lot of martial arts a lot of
great beasts special effects a lot of
wires and a lot of fun Russell Crowe and
Lucy Liu are the strongest links in this
movie I mean they're they're the acting
talent right there generally speaking
most everyone else in this movie they're
acting yeah that great all those martial
arts movies and their awesome acting
Russell Crowe kicks total ass he has a
knife that saws people in half you still
don't know what kind of movie this is
yet really
usually I'd like movies like this to
have deeper characters but when the
movie slows down and takes time to try
to develop its characters that's when
the movie actually kind of gets slow
being boring I was like come on go back
to killing each other and kicking each
other's asses that that was cool I
recognize this movie like this is not
going to be for everybody there will
definitely be a collection of people who
will be like this movie's completely
yaki the characters have new depth is
another two ative falls on Ed lemare
something but violence sex mine it will
be pornography what doesn't make the
movie bad for what it is is it an
excellent masterpiece no it's not not
even for a martial arts movie usually I
would say a movie like this would be a
good time if you're drunk and I kind of
want to give it that writing not as a
negative but just as a fact not as
though yeah I'd be a good time if you're
drunk but more like it yeah be a good
time if you're drunk you know it's a
positive but I don't want people to miss
hear me so I will say the man with the
iron fists is a good time no alcohol
required for fans of kick-ass cheesy
martial arts movies with an absurd
amount of violence and sex you know who
you are out there this is for you
bracing your favorite martial arts movie
of all time what would it be
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you